welcome you to the Richard M karp
distinguished lecture today my name is
Sandy Irani and I'm the associate
director of the Simon's Institute and
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
the Institute we are the world's leading
venue for collaborative research and
theoretical computer science The
Institute was founded in 2012 with a
very generous Grant from the Simons
foundation and we bring together
researchers from all over the world in
theoretical computer science and related
fields and also sponsor the next
generation of young scientists
um before we get started today's event
is hybrid so I want to go over some
Logistics if you're in the room you can
just raise your hand and ask a question
if you're online I will be monitoring
the Q a and um and I can ask your
question for you
um and this uh lecture series uh was
founded to honor the contributions of
Richard karp the founding director of
the Simon's Institute and to celebrate
his many contributions in founding the
field of theoretical computer science
um we'd like to thank many of the donors
to this that the fund that makes these
talks possible
we feature leading researchers and
theoretical computer science and related
fields and the talks are aimed at a
broad scientific audience
so um and we're very grateful to the
people who have donated to make this
lecture series possible and today I'm
delighted to welcome our speaker
Jennifer Chase who comes to us all the
way from UC Berkeley's division of
computer Computing data science and
Society where she serves as the
associate Provost and Dean of the school
of information she spent 23 years at
Microsoft most recently as a technical
fellow and co-founded and led three
interdisciplinary labs in Cambridge
Massachusetts New York City and Montreal
a member of the National Academy of
Science and the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences
um as probably everyone in this room
knows Chase is one of the uh inventors
of graphons so that's going to be the
topic of her talk today so Jennifer will
tell us about graphons and graphexes and
and limits and modes of large sparse
graphs so thank you and join me in
welcoming Jennifer thank you
[Applause]
so thanks to everyone who's here let me
see what is best for you where should I
right here you want me to stay here
please okay it's so hard to get me to
stand still
okay
okay so
um what I'm going to do is talk about
graph funds and Graphics both as limits
and of models of large sparse graphs
um this is going to be probably on the
statistics and math side of the carp
lectures so it it will contain a lot of
math uh and for those of you who uh went
to my tutorial in the graphons boot camp
you'll see some of the same materials so
that
if you in in case you weren't in that
tutorial or in case you were and you
didn't get it all you have another
chance to see it
okay so I'm gonna first talk about dense
graph convergence and then
um convergence for sparse graphs of
unbounded
um unbounded degree and then I'm going
to do a statistical approach
um with talking about
um a notion of convergence for graphs we
call sampling convergence I'll do that
first for dense and then for sparse
graphs and then I will tell you what
graph X's are and they turn out in a
very natural sense to be the completion
the mathematical completion of the space
of graphons and I'll give you an example
which shavik is here he's one of the
co-authors of that example
okay so what is a graph well graphon is
a symmetric function of two variables
which can represent two things it can be
a limit of a sequence of dense graphs or
if I just give you the function you can
use it as a random model for large dense
graphs to Generate random random graphs
so what is the random model do well
given a feature space so you should
think of these as let's say that I'm
trying to generate the LinkedIn graph
okay and so uh let's say that I have
certain attributes certain features my
features may be my gender or my age my
educational level my what industry I'm
in
um my you know
even my political leanings they they can
be all kinds of things so they may know
about my political leanings depending on
you know who I say uh that I like what
they say and I don't like what they say
even though that wouldn't have been
something they would have explicitly
asked me so I I have a feature space and
a measure on that feature space and I'm
going to have a function on a two
variable function on that feature space
cross itself so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to generate a lot of the
individuals on what will be this social
network I'll generate somebody who has
my attributes I'll you know randomly
generate somebody who as Christians
attributes or Sandy's attributes okay
According to some mu okay that that
measure mu and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to flip a w of x i x j so a
double you of my features and Christians
features so I take this function and I
evaluate it on that and that's the
probability that I'm going to connect to
Christian on this network that I've
created
so if I have some Network
um
maybe this is a growing Network and I
can ask for
what function might describe the limit
of this growing Network
or I could say I give you the W I
somehow know the W of this network and
now you could Generate random
realizations of it
okay so here's some some heuristics I'm
going to take the adjacency Matrix of
the graph and if there's a one
indicating that two
um two vertices are connected I'm going
to put a black circle and if there's a
zero indicating that they're not I'm
going to put a white circle and then I
could just think of this as you know I
could shrink it down to the unit Square
I could take the limit
and it kind of looks like this okay or
the random graph G and P with P equals a
half kind of looks like that
and what I get out of that one is the
constant function one half
and what about the permutations of
vertices okay these two are the same I
could get from one to the other by
permuting the vertices well it turns out
so permutations in the graph what does
that correspond to in the limit well
actually the limit is unique only up to
measure preserving bijection so that's
what survives whenever you see a b in
any of the papers it's Christian borgs
see if there's one C it's me if there's
a second C it's usually Henry Cohen L is
lovas sometimes lovas senior sometimes
lovas Junior okay
um
okay so here's a more formal definition
I can do a graph on on a sigma finite
measure space okay
um and it's a symmetric function
the empirical graph on of a graph is
kind of just what I showed you I take
the unit Square I divide it up into you
know 1 over n by 1 over n i set W to one
on the Square if there's an edge there
and zero otherwise so for any finite
graph I could write it as a piecewise
constant graph on so it's a way graph on
is also a way of representing any graph
so
um I'm gonna talk about
I'll start out by talking about just one
kind of convergence although in the
original work Christian to me and lotsy
Lovato
gummy we we
um had a lot of different Notions of of
limits so fries and Conan in 1999 uh
defined
um what they called a cut Norm okay so
even think of W2 as zero for the moment
okay what I want is I want the the cut
Norm of just one one graph W okay and it
looks like looks like a graph because
I'm thinking of w as the piecewise
constant graph on of that graph that I
have a picture of what I want to do with
W two is zero and I'm just talking about
the cut Norm of w is I want to take the
max cut through that graph so the cut
which gives me the largest sum of the
broken edges
and that's the cut Norm of that I could
also take the cut Norm of the difference
of two graphs
foreign
and W2 are defined over the same or even
over different spaces
I'm going to define the cut metric as
not just this
Norm that I have pictured there
okay but
Infamous
overall re-labeling so I want to find
the labeling of W1 that makes it look
closest to W2 okay and that's going to
be reflecting again permutation and
variance in the graphs okay
I'm I'm going to info over all measure
preserving bijections if I'm doing it on
finite graphs overall permutations
and we say that a sequence of graphs
converges to a graph on if they're
empirical graphons namely just the you
know uh piecewise constant functions on
the unit Square
converge to W in this metric for any of
them you can think about the max cut
through the graph because the empirical
graph ones are on finite graphs you
think of a Max cut through a graph or
you take two different graphs and you
take a difference between them and ask
for the max cut essentially through that
okay
and in
this work which I guess lotsy wrote a
lot about it in his book on graph funds
for sequences of dense graphs this cut
metric convergence is equivalent to many
other local and Global Notions of
convergence
that's not what I'm going to be talking
about here
okay so now let's talk about sparse
graphs of unbounded degree
so
you know what I didn't even tell you
what a dense crap was although I assume
you know it but let me just go back a
dense graph if I have
um n vertices a dense graph has of order
N squared edges in it okay and it's it's
growing I want to think there's a
positive probability that one site is
going to be connected to another site a
sparse graph is something for which
that's not true the number of edges
divided by the number of vertices goes
to zero okay now you could have a sparse
graph in which you have very few
edges like a square lattice okay or any
bounded number or you could have
unbounded degree okay and that's most of
the sparse graphs that we think of for
networks look much more like unbounded
degree okay there's some people who are
connected to many many other people
there's there's there's no set well
there may be technically in some of
these you know um in some of these
platforms but in in principle there
should be no limit to the number of
followers somebody could have on Twitter
okay
um
so I was going to make a Twitter joke
but since this is being filmed maybe I
shouldn't make a Twitter okay so the
models that are used in the literature
to model a sparse graph mostly just take
a dense graph and dilute it by some
Target density Row in okay so they just
dilute it so
um a lot of you know the urdish renum
random graph which actually corresponds
to constant graph mods well if I take p
and I make it scale like 1 over n that's
essentially by Divine like dividing
through by you know row is scaling like
one over n there okay
so what has been called the
inhomogeneous random graph so here
given a feature space
with a probability distribution on
features How likely someone on the
network is to be a woman How likely they
are to have a PhD How likely whatever
um
uh and a graph on
which tells me how likely two
individuals with different
um with different attributes are to to
be connected and to Target density
so I'm going to choose these according
to Pi I'm going to say now the
probability that they're connected to
each other is Rowan
times W of x i and X okay so I'm scaling
it just like I do in the earnest when
you graph when I multiply by 1 over n
okay
um I I don't want that to get bigger
than
um one because probability is bigger
than one or not not very good so I took
them in with one and I'm going to call
the resulting random graph an
inhomogeneous random graph at Target
density row N and I'm going to give it
these are all the realizations of it I'm
going to say GN is just G of rho n times
W it's the random Ensemble that's
created by
you know at size n multiplying by row N
and then saying the probability that x i
is connected to x j is w
okay
so
for sparse graph sequences
the limit that we defined previously is
zero because you know the the L1 Norm of
w goes to zero and so the the limit is
zero
so what do we do
well what I want to do is I want to
divide through by the norm so first we
started out with this thing on 0 1 I'm
sorry an initiative had it look like
that 0 1 looks like it's the net that
this is the positive quadrant okay
um and so this you know there it's
either a one or a zero right
now what if I take
this
and I divide through by the norm of
doubling okay because I'm worried that
that thing that that this whole thing is
just going to go to zero when I take the
limit so if I divide through by the norm
then I have a reasonable chance that it
won't go zero that it'll approach
something non-trivial
and we're going to say that GN is
convergent if there's some graph on
such that the distance between the
rescaled version so I'm taking my
individual gns but I'm dividing them
through by their Norm if that converges
to W then I say it converges
in this rescale sense
and it turns out and this is a lot of
work okay this is I don't know
um many many many dozens of pages
if this is the inhomogeneous random
craft so if what I'm doing is I'm
starting from a w I give you a w you
walk into LinkedIn and somebody says hey
this is the W of LinkedIn generate some
random Ensemble of those okay now
multiply by some row N okay
if I generate from a w then it turns out
that in this rescaled limit where I
divide through by the norm it is going
to go to that W so this is a faithful so
when I've given you that W when you
walked into LinkedIn and I told you to
start generating things randomly
it was a reasonable thing for me to do
because it would converge that provided
the densities going to zero and it's
unbounded right it it doesn't
um uh the
um
um the the the degrees are not bounded
by anything
okay
so this is a reasonable thing to do we
did this
the last time I gave a lecture here a
lot of people do these things and then
you start looking at
um you start looking at uh you know
um all all kinds of
algorithms that that you can do with
these and you look at
um you know uh uh the the representation
theorems of them
so here's an alternative sparse graph
model so the first one was I gave you a
w
and you
you know you have all these xi's and you
generate edges and you multiply by
rowing this is something totally
different it's a graph on process grown
and fox were the first people to do this
in the case in which
W looked like
um
f of x times F of Y or f of x times G of
Y rank one okay
um and also see um Roy invites here or
invite chamoy
um so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to fix the sigma finite measure space
and a graph on
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
at each time t
I'm going to let x x c t be the set of
all the individuals that I've generated
with these different features okay
and then I'm going to go I'm going to
look at them and I'm going to connect x
i and XJ with probability W of x i x j
I'm going to remove isolated vertices
and I'm going to say okay I've got a
finite graph at time t
so let's look at an example of this
we'll see this example later again
um so uh
so the the earliest time X2 was born so
I've got somebody with a certain set of
features okay and then at the next time
X3 is born and then X1 is born and then
X4 is born and now what I do is I look
at I flip all these coins I flip the X2
X3 coin and O turns out that I do get
the this W of X1 X2 I do get an edge
there I flip the X to X1 coin I don't
get anything I flip the X2 X4 coin and I
get something okay so this is what I
have now I go on I look at X3 X3 is not
doesn't get an edge to X4
um X1 doesn't get an edge to anyone okay
so this is where I am
at the next time
other things have have come in
um so I guess this this was just X is
organized in some way that was a time
along the arrow
um and so X5 X6 and X7 have have come in
so I've generated three more in
individuals when I go and I flip my new
coins I keep the coins on the first ones
to be just what they were before okay so
I'm not changing them and the
inhomogeneous one I'm effectively
changing them when I renormalize by the
density here I'm not changing them I
leave those flipped coins between X1 X2
X3 and X4 I flip coins between X5 and
everybody nothing happens okay no no
um edges I flip coin between X
um six and it attaches to two of the
ones that were there and I flipped the
X7 coin X1 is still in the background it
was just wiped out oh but now X7 connect
to X1 so now X1 appears maybe X5 will
appear later okay
so what is the corresponding limit
notion this is this is this process
right
well we already talked about this
there's a different way of doing this so
this is with Nina Holden oh the the
um person on the previous work was
euphao in addition to Henry cone so cc
is Chase cone usually
um
so let's do something really different
let's
stretch the metric
by the square root of the norm of w so
here what I'm doing is I took my unit
square
and instead of dividing through by the
density and letting these get big I
multiplied by the square root of w and
so they're getting smaller and smaller
and they're getting stretched down into
the whole positive quadrant
okay and I'm going to say
it's convergent if there exists a graph
on which converges to this stretched
sequence
and so what we showed with Nina Holden
is that
this graph on process converges so let's
say now I take
I I do the generation as I told you okay
I gave you a w and I told you just let
your poisson points get you know let
individuals join LinkedIn okay when they
come in they connect with the previous
people who were there you know oh poor
X1 didn't get connected but later
somebody connects to X1 and I look at
and I generate realizations of something
which looks like that well those
actually converge to this W okay
that was used to generate them
okay
um now honestly uh
the measure on
Mr reels because now we have scaled
so I just can do the big measure on the
pasta wrist first
so
actually I've been cheating a little bit
without some extra technical conditions
Mass could have gone up to Infinity for
the rescaled graphons or out to Infinity
could have like got pushed out far in
the positive right quadrant okay and
just gotten lost there
in which case we won't get subsequential
uh convergence so the solution for
rescaled graph funds we developed a a
theory which obeyed a certain notion of
regularity which we called uniform
regularity which ruled out pathological
sequences and it's under those
conditions if W was uniformly regular
that all of this worked
that's with eufasia on Henry Cohen for
stretched graphones with Nina Holden and
Henry Cohen
um we had another way of ruling out
pathological sequences with too much
mass drifting off to Infinity so we
ruled those out but now what I'm going
to talk to you about today is actually
catching that mass that's trying to
drift off okay so it's a different way
of doing it we do that with something
called Graphics okay so we don't put on
a regularity condition
we catch that Mass
okay so so far graphons
we have these rescaled or stretched
limits okay where we divide through by
the norm or stretch the metric by square
root of the norm
and once we get a w we can Generate
random graph models and these two things
have a consistency between them
okay now we're going to go back and do a
primer on exchangeability which I've
done here before I know Christian has
done it but you know it's always nice to
see things that we already know
um and really if you were sitting around
in 1937 you would think that definiti
was brilliant as I do whenever I teach a
basic probability class okay so what is
an exchangeable sequence an exchangeable
sequence X1 X2 Etc infinite exchangeable
sequence means that for any finite
subset
um the two subsequences have the same
joint probability distribution I only
talk about them for the finite subsets
okay now
if something is identically distributed
okay then it certainly is exchangeable
but not vice versa in other words there
are things that are exchangeable that
are not identically distributed okay so
for example the poly urn where when I
grab out a red ball I put back in two
red balls when I grab out of green ball
I put my you know and so obviously that
looks like it's sequence dependent
because if I grabbed out a lot of red
balls in the beginning I have so many of
them so it's sequence dependent
well definiti in 1937 said that
exchangeable sequences are actually
close to independent
in the sense that when conditioned on a
parameter which happens to be a random
variable Sigma algebra at Infinity they
are independent so you can condition on
something and with that they are
independent okay so instead of taking a
regular probability to use a conditional
probability condition on this parameter
p okay so definitive thermos has an
infinite sequence is exchangeable if and
only if there's a probability measure
such that if I do the following let me
choose P between 0 and 1 according to Mu
then let me choose x i IID
0 1 with parameter P so in other words
the probability that I pull out a red
ball equals one minus the probability
that I pull out a green ball equals P
okay well some P by the way P happens to
be
the limit of
the number of balls
which are red okay
or sorry the the limit of the number
given that it's read so the density is
actually a random variable measurable
with respect to the sigma algebra and
infinity although you don't normally
think of just this constant as that but
it is a random variable measurable with
respect to the signal algebra
so it's it's kind of amazing when you
think about definitely right this thing
that should be very dependent turns out
to be conditionally independent if I
condition on this parameter P which is
the probability of a red ball so is
there an analog of definiti for arrays
okay we had sequences so is there an
analog this turns out to be the oldest
Hoover theorem and how about arrays
corresponding to sparse graphs instead
of dense graphs
well this is a second motivation for the
stretch graph and for graph axis
okay so what is an exchangeable array
um it's said to be jointly exchangeable
so just think of it like a big Matrix
that goes on forever okay if I take any
finite n and I do any permutation on a
sequence of n distinct indices okay I'm
going to get the same joint probability
distribution so if I do permutations the
same permutation on the row and the
column of my Matrix okay
and an infinite random graph is
exchangeable with the distribution of
its adjacency Matrix is invariant under
finite permutations of the indices
so how can such a distribution be
generated is there an analog of definiti
is there that there's some parameter
which is random variable measurable with
respect to the sigma algebra and
infinity and the answer is no not even
for dense graphs there's a much larger
space that characterizes exchangeable
arrays this is the Altus Hoover theorem
which I'll State here but basically in
in doing the dense version of what we're
then going to do for sparse graphs I'm
going to give you a proof of it later in
the talk
so
what all this Hoover says this is an
analog of definity is that an infinite
array is jointly exchangeable if and
only if so just like definitive
sequencing is exchangeable if and only
if there's a measure on the equivalence
class of dense graphons
such that a can be generated as follows
the Matrix a I'm going to choose a
possibly random element of of the
equivalence class of dense graphons this
is a rewriting of what all this interfer
said and it requires that we know about
the uniqueness stuff which they didn't
know about
choose a uniformly random infinite
sequence of individuals with their
features and connect I and J
independently
okay so in other words while definiti
says that the infinite exchangeable
sequences are just conditionally
independent Bernoulli sequences with
some random parameter P the oldest
Hoover theorem says that infinite
jointly exchangeable arrays are just
random dense graphics
okay
so all this and Uber was not expressed
the language of graphons
um but uh
but in in hindsight this is clear and
actually
um Tim Austin and dioconus and Johnson
really pointed out the correspondence
okay so our sparse graph mods associated
with some exchangeable infinite process
the same way that Bernoulli sequences
are associated with infinite
exchangeable sequences and dense
graphons are associated with infinitely
jointly exchangeable arrays
and not in the rescaled graph on Theory
okay and we normalize the height
but if we Define this projective graph
on process that we were defining before
and its corresponding Edge process which
I will Define for you
then we can use some general theorems of
callenberg on measures that will allow
us to say something
okay so what's an exchangeable edge
process or measure what I'm going to do
is I'm going to consider a locally
finite Edge process what that means is
that in any finite region or only a
finite number so what I'm going to do is
I'm I'm going to take a graph I'm going
to take its adjacency Matrix and I'm
going to let the vertices of the graph
be labeled by time
so across the bottom of this oops across
the bottom of this I'm going to have
time going this way and then time going
that way
and I'm going to have an Associated Edge
measure on the positive quadrant with
Point masses at the Times corresponding
to edges of G so what I'm going to do is
that at some time I'm going to get
an edge between I and J and I'm going to
put a Delta function there
and then I'm going to get you know and
and obviously these are going to get
much much sparser as I go out
so this is just a collection of Point
masses where the edges have shown up
and I'm going to say the measure is
jointly exchangeable so this is a
measure now it's a set of Delta
functions
if its distribution is on invariant
under finite interval permutation so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take like some finite piece here and
permute it with an with some other
finite pieces here and I'll do the same
on the on the y-axis okay
so in the original work on graphons
there was a local notion of subgraph
convergence which was shown to be
equivalent to
convergence in the cut metric here we're
going to do a different notion of
convergence local notion so what I'm
first going to do it on demand scratch
so given a dense graph what I'm going to
do is I'm going to choose
you know all my individuals with their
features uniformly at random
and then I'm going to Output the induced
subgraph on a subset of the entire graph
K elements of the entire graph with
edges e so in other words I'm going to
pick
K of the points in this graph
and I'm going to connect them if they
were connected in the underlying graph
and if they weren't connected in the
underlying graph I won't connect them so
it's an induced sub graph I have this
whole graph I choose K points and you
know some of those points might have
been connected to other things I didn't
choose when I sampled but the ones where
both where where I got both edges
I they they get included okay and I say
a sequence of graphs is called sampling
convergent if the distribution of these
samples converges for all K so for all
you know 12 uh vertex things that
converges for all you know 13 vertex
things the distribution of graphs can
converges okay
so what is the limit well it's a
collection of probability distributions
on these finite graphs 12 size 13
thoughts it's also a projective
collection because every one of these
was a subset of the one before we didn't
rename things or redo things or re-flip
our coins okay which are implicitly
doing in the rescaled case
and so since it's monotone by komogara
there's an infinite random graph that
comes out of this
so an infant random graph we know we can
express as an infinite random array
it's permutation symmetric
it converts
how it got generated and it also happens
to be extremal it can't be written as a
non-trivial convex combination of two
other probability distributions and this
just follows from the fact that the sub
arrays
so I take any
sub array on insights and then the other
on K sites on like
K sub array of my of my thing and then
the rest of it and those are independent
of each other
so the sampling convergence sequence of
dense graphs is an extremal
exchangeable array
but that's just what the all the Aldous
Hoover theorem says that a symmetric
extremely exchangeable array if if you
have one of those there's a function w
such that you can get a by first
choosing these these
um individuals with their features and
then choosing the entries
Bernoulli W of x i x j okay so this is
so this W is really the analog of fixing
a p in definity for us
okay so this is a this is a graph on
and then there's a lot of Historical
Notes on this which I'm not going to go
into
okay so what do I do for sparse graph so
I just told you I have this local notion
of sampling convergence on dense graphs
which if if I look at it that way
it's really easy to get all this Hoover
out of it and to see that W the function
W for the for for the array the graph on
is the equivalent of the parameter P for
a a
um an an infinite sequence okay if I
condition on the function W everything's
independent and similarly definiti if I
condition on the constant P everything's
independent
and then it goes both ways okay
okay so now what I want to do is I want
to have a sampling procedure
but
um if I just sample without doing
anything everything's going to go to
zero
um
so
right because the the number of of edges
in this sample is K choose two I have to
pick K points
times the the density okay and the edge
density is going to zero so for sparse
graphs
um oh sorry uh
okay so yes it converges to to the empty
graph because
so the idea me and Christian borgs and
Henry Cohn and Victor vich who had
worked with Dan Roy on the
um
on the the uh graph on and graph facts
process but not on the limits
was to define a sampling procedure or k
choose two grows like one over row so
that'll stop things I mean at least on
the surface of it it looks like it'll
stop things from going to zero and it
does so we call this poisson sampling
so I've got a puzzle process okay so I'm
choosing these features so I'm choosing
individuals
each individual gets generated with all
their features
but the intensity of that poisson
process instead of just being time
is divided by the square root of the
number of edges
okay
and I'm going to Output the induced
subgraph so so think about this if the
number of edges is going to zero
well if if it's going to zero
um
it if the number of edges divided by the
density is is is going to zero I would
normally have a problem but
over time now what I'm doing is that
um I'm picking fewer and fewer and fewer
points okay so I want to Output the
induced subgraph after deleting all
isolated vertices
and with this Choice what's the number
of edges well the number of edges is the
number of edges to begin with
okay and then I sample
um I sample with density p and I have to
pick
the left edge of the the left vertex of
the edge and the right vertex of the
edge so that's P times V squared
um and so this turns out to be uniform
in the density okay so the density is
gone from this which is good
okay so we say a sequence of graphs is
sampling convergent
if this poisson of the graphs converges
so we're not sampling in a constant way
we're sampling in this scaled way
and therefore by compactness it has a
subsequence which is sample link
convergence so what is this limit okay
what is this limit
well it's some process of unlabeled
graphs
okay
you know we'll just foreign
letter T over
square root of the number of edges we
get another point we get another point
so it's just this process
so is there an analog of all this all
this Hoover giving a more compact
representation of this process remember
this and Eddie says for a sequence
you've got one parameter which gives a
compact representation
of a process of generating elements of a
sequence in the infinite sequence
um
for dense graphs which are represented
by
these
matrices right
the compact representation is
the function W such that if you have W
you can treat them as if they're
independent
well is there a more compact
representation than the entire process
okay probably not a constant probably
not a function
so the preliminary answer is that we
want to extend the notion of graphons
over probability spaces
two graph runs over finite Sigma spaces
and use these to Define
this graph on process so
again what are we doing we are
generating all these these individuals I
come into this room and I generate you
and I generate you and okay
and then I'm going to connect them with
probability W of
my attributes and sanjukta's attributes
I'm going to remove the isolated
vertices so just like I did before okay
just like I I did before that oh number
one came in because number seven
connected to it
so does this converge to a graph on
process
well not not quite okay
so Roy invites
um
talked about a a different kind of
object which was an extension of
graphics
so they talked about a graph facts
which was a triple it was a function
just like our graph on functions an
integrable graph on okay which
represented the probability that that
someone with my attributes and someone
with Christians attributes connects to
each other
then
for me it gives me a star it tells me oh
how many people have just connected to
me okay
um am I tweeting enough whatever
um I mean I know that Twitter is
directed and we're not talking directly
and think about stars in Twitter okay
and then I have some constant which is a
a dust in intensity
and so you can have this graph facts
process
so I'm going to generate these guys like
I did before I'm going to use W try to
connect
every pair of them
but whenever I get one when it's born
next one is born I give it its own
little star X2 is born I give it its own
little star
X3 X4 so depending on the attributes how
might be different like who wants to
have a mutual connection with me versus
you know just this
kind of star that might grow
and then I'm going to add isolated edges
at that frame so why would someone look
at this thing oh and I'm going to remove
all isolated vertices now put me on
well so
the reason one might want to look at
this thing and so this is the
representation that Christian boards
Henry cone Victoria tonight and I did is
that if GN is sampling convergent
to Gene then there exists
a graph x
such that in distribution so I have this
process
this is in distribution the process that
would have been generated by that
Graphics Okay so
instead of just saying oh I give you a a
g and you're going to generate a graph
which is things connected to each other
okay and you get a whole ensemble of
those now you're going to get an
ensemble of these weird things where
you're going to see whether they're
connected to each other
but you're also going to grow a star for
each one and then you're going to have
some
you know
Lonely Hearts couples well not Lonely
Hearts but they're they're happy but
they're just couples okay lonely couples
oh and so the proof uses callenberg's
theorem for exchangeable random measures
to prove this okay so that's a
complicated theorem with like 10
conditions in it in fact
in fact uh with shavik and
um
uh
superbroto San and Christian and I we
discovered there was even a problem in
that um in that callenberg's theorem as
written which nobody had noticed before
even though it had been used probably
hundreds of times but it was such
complicated uh conditions that
actually one of the conditions was wrong
I mean the theorem wasn't true and you
had to modify that that condition
um hopefully most of the cases that had
used it the modified condition was also
true
um so uh
Okay so
what had happened here is that
we so in this last piece of work
we introduced sampling convergence we
established the theorem that's there
and we showed that this sampling
convergence notion that we had
introduced
is equivalent to this stretch version
that we had done with Nina Holden
for graph sequences without too many
low-degree vertices
so this turns out to be graphexes are
completions of sparse graphs so in other
words I could either put conditions that
prevent Mass from leaking out to
infinity or I could say let the mass
leak
what do the limits look like and the
limits look like
things with the underlying Network that
you would generate
from
W of X and Y
stars that you would generate from s
and component of dust at some constant
density
so why does sampling lead to this okay
well the heuristic picture
um this is just the the heuristics but I
want to analyze this poisson process
okay where I have M edges but then I
sample and I only retain P of my
vertices and then
um right in in and the induced subgraph
left on those
um
uh K vertices chosen with probability
so I'm going to decompose my set of
vertices
and to those whose degrees there will
are of order square root of M
the number of edges
a low degree part where they're little o
of square root of that
and a high degree part where it goes to
Infinity the square root of that okay so
those are the three parts of my graph
and then I'm going to sample
My Graph so C of p is going to be what's
left of the of the
um
you know where it's order square root of
them
LP and HP so I just
um sample all of these with with density
P which is scaling like 1 over square
rooted out
so
h
contains only little o square root of M
vertices so it's going to be empty
okay
see could contain little R square root
of M times because I just set
order
but let's assume it's really a border
like constant times square root of M
um it's a constant times square root of
M then C will contain CP I'll have a
sample the P fraction of them but
remember p is scaling like 1 over square
root of M so there's a constant number
so there's Theta T vertices and
expectation each of expected degree
Theta of T why because you know over
time more and more of the new guys who
come in attached to me
now let's look at l
okay these are the low degree vertices
well
um let's look at the probability that a
low degree vertex actually is connected
to two other vertices so this triangle
here okay here's my low degree vertex
but it's connected to two or more other
vertices okay
so in order to keep this and to keep
this vertex this vertex and this vertex
I have to keep me and the two things I'm
connected to that's P cubed okay and
this is growing like
the the degree and this is growing like
the degrees and that's D Squared when I
multiply it all out and I sum it up I
find that that's going to zero Okay so
there's nothing in L of degree two or
more
they're all of degree one
okay
get connected to one other
so in the limit the edges with two
vertices in LP are just a pair
this dust which happens with some
density
right some constant density
the
um
if I have LP and CP
okay so this is low degree and the core
so let's just go back for a second and
look at that picture
so if if I have
um
one is a low degree vertex having degree
one and the other is more in the core
okay then those are part of the star and
otherwise they're in the actual chord
so I just want to give you an example of
this and this has worked with
um uh work with shavik
Dara and um and sugar Frodo Sen
um so the configuration model normally
says let's just
um give
uh everybody did um what what their
degrees are this is a rank one model and
then do a random pairing to pair them up
with each other so you know Christian
has 27 things 27 that he's gonna so he
has 27 half edges I have 12 so I have 12
half edges and everybody here has some
number and we just randomly pair them
with each other
okay
um
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to consider the empirical degree
distribution so I'm going to have
these Delta functions but instead of the
degree I'm going to scale it by the sum
of the degrees square root of the sum of
the degrees okay
scale up by the square root of the sum
and I'm going to have a poisson process
so the number of points
K in this is a plus Omron variable
that has
remember we divided by the square root
of of n well this is the square root of
M sitting here
okay and so this is IID it's distributed
in this way
and so here is the theorem that we came
up with
so let the max of D I be of order the
total number of edges then this
configuration model is sampling
convergent if and only if the density
goes vaguely so what is this big thing
tell us this this big thing means that
if I put a function here it converges
for all x with compact support in here
so I'm not touching 0 or or Infinity I'm
not touching 0 or Infinity because this
F has compact support
so what is the a
the a
here is
well let me just put the rest of this in
this a
if I look at it
turns out to be
the degree distribution for small
degrees
okay for degrees that are less than
Epsilon times square root of L so there
are the parts that this function f would
not be seeing because they're getting
very near zero okay
so this is the asymptotic fraction of
low degree half edges
they do who are physicists here this is
the same kind of integral you see in the
Bose condensation this weird thing that
captures this thing you almost think
shouldn't be there okay or for those of
you who know Mayan Christians work with
Costas escolacus from I don't know
probably around 2000 on this first to
Market we got an integral like that
which showed that somebody would be born
who would have a positive fraction of
all future things that are connected to
them that that was kind of a rich gets
richer
um so anyway it's this kind of
interesting thing where
you know it's the asymptotic fraction of
low degree edges what happened in the
work with Nina
Hogan was we basically ruled this out so
what goes on here what goes on here is
that
this is what my w is this is a
multi-graph x
which is what you get from a
configuration model you don't just have
one Edge in many just
so I'm going to join different inj with
poisson so that's what my w is and I can
also have loops in it
my star function is just X scaled by
this
residual Part near zero
okay
this constant representing the residual
part near zero and these pairs are just
the square of that
okay so this is kind of a richer class
of limits
so
before we talked about
graphs going to graphons and here if we
do this sampling limit and we don't
exclude anything we don't say I'm going
to put on a condition to rule out
pathologies we just let the pathologies
happen
the pathologies give you this richer
space where you have these edges but you
also have stars and this dust of
to
compare to each other so anyway when
people talk about Graphics is that's
what they're talking about this kind of
richer space with pair functions
individual feature functions and these
little things that just connect to one
another
the virtual audience is client but do
other questions I'm sorry it was very
nasty so I don't know we're going to
jump in here but um
okay
so thank you for the nice talk uh so
when you're modeling a sparse graph
which of the
graph conferences we use for example if
we raise scales one or the stretch how
do you choose to like so most of the
results that have been done so far are
using the rescaled one because it's
easier you just multiply by something
there's no underlying process it's as if
I'm not keeping the same edges as I grow
If I multiply by a different row every
time it's as if I'm not keeping the same
edges
so that's a more probabilistic View and
the estimation theorems and a lot of the
theorems have been done for that
this is a more statistical view it's
projected it actually corresponds more
to something growing so less has been
developed so far for graph X's
um what we showed in um
in earlier work if we put on the
conditions that limited things is that
these are actually describing different
sets of graphs so it might be that for
some things
but this is more appropriate
um this this this process way of doing
it and it might be for other things that
the just the rescaled way is a better
way of doing
but they're disjoint actually
yes
yeah so thank you very much so I was
wondering maybe maybe a little bit but
uh so this is what you showed with this
stars and the dust very romantic
um
um that that is what you will see in the
limit but the question was also a little
bit that's really around like can you
from limit construct something finer
yeah yeah so I didn't really get uh get
completely how do you go about that so
what are you given and how you construct
something finite so what I could say is
hey it turns out
when I
when you walk into Facebook and you're
told you might not just be given a
um uh
a graph on you might be given a graph x
you might be given a pair function a
star function and a dust function you
might be given those three functions and
that might be the best way to describe
this now
oh how I Define the random graph so the
way I Define the random graph is you're
given these
two functions you function two variables
function one variable and a constant and
so what I do is
as things are born I flip my w- weighted
coin with the attributes of both and I
connect in the process as right so
another voice comes in so so you just
enter the scene
you are born with your set of attributes
you take everything that has been born
before and you flip your w- weighted
coin with them your attributes How
likely are you to connect to sanjukta or
to Sandy or to shuvi or to Christian or
any Agony okay and then
you also are born with a star function
which says how many others who never
connect to anything else are going to
get connected to you and there are and
separately from that you should be
generating this constant dust around but
when you're born you are born with these
two functions one I stick your value
into the W function which is the
probability you connect to someone else
and two this function which says how
many
otherwise unattached things are gonna
are and this function will depend on my
birth time
the function no no well it will depend
on your attributes so your attribute
right I mean I'm going to compare
your attributes and Sandy's attributes
and say what are the what's the
probability you would connect to each
other but I'm also just going to say
wow you might be a star you know you
might or or you know if I don't know uh
I don't know who who the biggest stars
are in these things because I don't
follow this stuff but you know if I'm I
don't know some big singer or something
you know I I'm born with a with a big
star function and if I'm an
mathematician I'm born with a much
smaller star function
take the microphone so that if somebody
happens to be
so via vertices up this this features
are born in time because you have a
poisson process which gets denser and
dancers
the Stars also get denser so actually
you have some attractivity
as sort of somebody who has tons of fans
oh yeah
times times time time so in other words
as time goes on you collect more and
more fans
so it's like a fitness it's like you're
born with a certain Fitness for
attracting fans
so it's a little bit like
a wonderful questions
um so it is essential that you do have
the stars with degree square root of
offend right
or greater than square root of n
right yeah because because if you you
like configuration model principally
speaking you can construct a regular
graph of configuration wall but not in
that limit right because that was scaled
so that configuration model that we grew
was
scaled here
um
so
right what what I was doing was I was
um
um maybe even one further back
here
so you see I'm I'm scaling it by this so
this poisson random variable is scaling
like n over square root of Ln
everything goes to the Dust
yeah one
one just get dust yeah so those regular
configuration model is only dust which
maybe makes sense but yeah okay thank
you very much it's much more clear now
thank you
any other questions
thank you
so I have uh well might be an even more
basic clarifying question in which case
I can ask it offline
um why are why is the graph on our
Graphics process uh it was hard for me
to understand why that gives a sparse
graph
um if for example just like the if the
dust if you're generating you know edges
with some uniform probability uh why do
you get something sparse at the end of
the day maybe I was missing some scaling
why do you get I I mean I am
I am setting it up so that I get a
non-trivial sparse limit so I am
dividing through or multiplying by
whatever is necessary to get me
um something other than zero the way I
did it for dense graphs I would get
limits but they'd be zero and so I want
to get which is accurate in some sense
but it's not what we're looking for they
all converge to the same point if we
treat them as if they're dense graphs
okay so this is a way of scaling it so
that you see the non the non-triviality
of it I don't know if that
um
okay I think the answer is I should
stare at the definitions again but
anyway thanks for a nice talk okay you
wanna
um so one the simplest way to see it
so the simplest way to see it is you
have this W which now lives on the
on the quadrant right but it's an L1
okay so it can't contain too much mass
so it it can't contain too much mass at
Infinity right you can imagine has to
Decay and now you put your percent Point
process which gets denser and denser so
it tests out more and more of this
thinner and thinner tail of the graphone
and as a consequence as you raise sort
of the density of your poisson process
if you think of this any constant area
around the origin you will generate a
dense graph there but then you add so
many of these poisson points which I
mean there are infinitely many in
principle and some of them will still
connect to at least some edges and they
will become the sparse part of a graph
so your graph will sort of have this
densish core but then it will have so
many
single fans and sort of even even sort
of if you just had this graph on it
still has sort of
spouse and sparse or parts of your graph
one which get connected more and more as
you add more and more person points that
that leads to sparsity
okay
[Laughter]
stuff
sorry I have a kind of very basic
question building on a previous question
that was asked
um basically when a new when new
individual comes in is the probability
of them being a star can is this can
this be proportional to time so like the
overall distribution is could be
changing in time oh see
um no I I I have an S of X which is just
your
um
you know which represents your Fitness
and then it just scales with time as
time is happening more as time is
Flowing yeah um
um
okay
so
um so here
um T times s of x
T okay so it's scaling so this is your
Fitness you're born s tells me
s is the function which tells me with
your attributes you have a certain
Fitness to be a star
and then over time it just scales with t
it is s necessarily constant or yes s is
s is independent of time so this s just
tells me these attributes
tell me your set of attributes your
features
and putting your latent Futures
everything and then I can tell you what
your Fitness is going to be and that
Fitness is constant at time in this
poisson process yes
so just a clarifying question so if we
like we try to model real life networks
and if you try to use this graphic graph
Graphics model so what will model
actually this particle come from Stars
actually it will if you try if you use
this model for like real life networks
so what we'll see Essentials graphs with
like a lot of stars or some stars and
that's that's it so that's it and that's
okay
if we take out the the like the the
notes with only one H then we'll do
something dense right
[Music]
um
think of it like like a like a social
network
so yeah but she's right that what is
surviving what is well yeah so think of
it
things that they those things that were
much much further out in the quadrant
those tend to contribute to your stars
and your dust right
um I mean I I I actually really like the
configuration model as a as a kind of
example of that
um
oh
okay so what's going on here is these
are the ones that are kind of much
further out and those are the ones that
are showing up that that
would have been gone if I had ruled out
basically the thing the the condition we
put on would mean a Holden rule this
stuff out okay so so in that sense stuff
that was leaking off to Infinity is the
stuff that's tending to contribute to
your stars and your dust but you still
have a rich Network
tits that you're growing anyway you're
just not losing those now you're
capturing those instead of having them
leak away
so continue the same topic uh
um yeah
uh yes yeah let's follow the rules
um so this W is is actually from from
Omega Square to zero one
squared isn't yeah well and that
prevents no no no no it's it's to R plus
it's R plus yes okay yes and that
prevents it from W can be unbounded yes
absolutely yeah
okay yeah okay
time to thank Jennifer again thank you